una de las peores tragedias de Corea del
Sur en años cientos de personas llegaron
al barrio y tehón para llorar a las más
de 150 víctimas que dejó la estampida
humana tras las celebraciones de
Halloween en el estrecho callejón que
conecta la principal Avenida del Barrio
con una concurrida zona de bares muchos
aún buscan a sus seres queridos no pude
encontrarla si revise la lista Pero el
nombre de quien Busco no está allí otros
lamentan lo ocurrido y gozan de su buena
suerte en los últimos meses había estado
viniendo a itvón pero no vine ayer
porque pensé que habría mucha gente y
estaba preocupado porque podían pasar
cosas malas estaba muy ansioso e
inquieto no pude dormir bien la opinión
pública surcoreana pone en duda los
estándares de seguridad según el
presidente la prioridad de su gobierno
será apoyar a las familias de las
víctimas y avanzar con una investigación
en profundidad para determinar las
causas de la tragedia
Halloween
una tragedia y un desastre que no
debería haber ocurrido tuvo lugar en el
donde seúl durante la celebración de
Halloween anoche expresó mis
condolencias a las víctimas del
incidente inesperado y espero que las
personas que resultaron heridas se
recuperen pronto mi corazón está con las
familias de las víctimas que sufren
angustia de perder a sus seres queridos
el gobierno designará un período de luto
nacional a partir de hoy hasta que el
incidente sea controlado y pondrá en
máxima prioridad en los asuntos
estatales la recuperación y las medidas
de seguimiento del incidente
según la agencia de noticias yonap entre
los muertos del incidente del sábado
había personas de China Irán Rusia
Estados Unidos Australia Uzbekistán
Vietnam kazajistán Austria sri lanka
Tailandia Noruega y Francia el
presidente de Estados Unidos y los
primeros ministros de Canadá y Reino
Unido expresaron sus condolencias en
redes sociales mientras varias estrellas
de k-pop como integrantes del grupo bts
cancelaron sus eventos musicales luego
de la tragedia